first of all congratulations thank you
and thanks for having us on this is
great thanks for having us on stage yeah
you're right in the middle of the Lavaca
living room here
you have to physically
be older it's true but mentally be
younger
yes that's an interesting trick it is
it's like living both
extremes of your own life in one
Spectrum yeah and I think that's what's
beautiful about the show is it's it's
looking ahead and backwards at the same
time right but in the midst of all of
that it's daring the audience to live in
the present mentally how do you get in
that space I meditate a lot I spend most
of my time when I'm not here resting
physically vocally spiritually I have to
really calm down because the energy
output that is required of me on stage
is so high that I spend most I'm a
professional wrestler
[Laughter]
you have to be persuaded to take this
part
it was a daunting Prospect to take on
the role
of a young girl who's on the brink of
Womanhood but who's also facing the end
of her life
and to play her without any attitude
about it or without commenting at all
on what it's like to be a teenager
teenagers
are young adults they need to be taken
seriously they want to be taken
seriously and so my main objective here
is to play someone who is real and who
wants to be seen yeah
you've done what 12 Broadway shows this
is my 13th Lucky 13 I hope
um how hard did they have to persuade
you
oh it was over a period of months
actually was it
classically trained lyric soprano yeah
and this is a teenager yeah so the sound
that I normally use when I sing yeah
would not be appropriate here
right I mean I could do that but then I
think people in the audience would be
like um that would I think that would
take you out of the story so I've had to
find a way to sing the score that is
both beautiful hopefully but also
um real and honest for that young girl
how did you find it
um I have fantastic teachers who've
helped me in coaches and I'm you know
I've been singing since I was six and I
also teach so it was a lot of trial and
error yeah you know sometimes I would
come in with a sound and everyone would
go whoa we went to the Opera you know or
sometimes I would try something you're
like now you sound like you're five so
like going back and that's true for the
physical life of the character too right
I had to find something I want to play a
person a young person with dignity
you know and not make fun of that
because I remember what that was like
the last thing we want is for people to
laugh at us ever unless you know it's
intentional but yeah so that's been a
journey
I don't I don't think I still have it
yet I'm still working I mean really I
really do think it's a process yeah I'm
still finding her and the audience helps
me to do that because they I can tell
when they're listening very very
carefully that I'm on to something and
sometimes I just hear people coughing
and looking through things in their
purse I'm like oh
come back to us come back
come back I remember when you walked out
at the beginning
and I thought okay this is really
interesting but how are all these young
people going to react to
an older person playing a 15 year old
kid
and they're mesmerized
what do you how do you explain what
happens with with the young people in
the audience do you think
I don't know I think it's it's such a
gift for me to give this to them yeah I
think for them to see an adult
play them with respect yeah and to hold
up the mirror and say I see you I
remember this vividly a lot of folks my
age don't remember their teenage years
very much but I do I've tried to forget
them most people
and I would like to
I do remember with quite a bit of
affection my teenage years so
um
a lot of that has to do with my friends
growing up and my family and uh you know
all this all the stuff that comes with
the finding who you are
um that many of many young folks have
talked to me after the show and been
just in tears and just telling me
um that they got it and that they I and
I always ask how am I doing you know how
did I do tonight and they're like oh you
nailed it yeah sometimes yeah I don't
think I don't think I nail it every
night but I I that's my aspect I'm
impressed that you were even willing to
ask that question of kids I would be
terrified of the answer
um I like to check in with people yeah
and I like to see because they'll
they're honest they will tell me you
know you're the most experienced Factor
on the stage
and and you're playing alongside in
terms of in terms of credits
and I say that because yeah there's a
whole range of life experience here
that's very rich but in terms of
professional experience yes without
question yeah and you're paired with
someone who's literally on the stage for
the first time
professionally
yes but Justin is an old soul and he
knows his way around a stage and he's a
very curious yeah
um loving caring person
and he's a great listener
and
that's probably the most important part
of being an actor
Justin described you as
goofy
shame on him to drop that like that oh
Justin
okay I'm gonna take this up with you but
that's part of what made him relax he
says
um well he's Goofy too I think I think
we meet each other on the goofy level
and then we meet each other on a way
deeper like sobbing in each other's arms
level and then most of the show is
somewhere in between yeah
a lot of the audience walks out
sobbing
I'm used to that Anthony you're used to
that yes how are you used to that I
don't know what it is
but I I want to connect with people on a
soul level I want when I'm on stage or
in the recording studio even you know
um in film and TV I want to reveal
something about what it means to be
alive and to do that you have to be raw
and you have to be very open
and there's something about my voice
when I just sort of get out of the way
that connects with people somehow it
means it's working
in a way right I think our story is
about
what what will it take for you to stop
and realize how precious life is yeah
and but we do it in a very subversive
way yeah and a very sort of hopefully a
witty hilarious way that kind of sneaks
up on you so you don't realize we kind
of seduce the audience and then by the
end you're like wait a second this is
where this is all going and there is a
catharsis there is a release that I
personally feel every night and I think
the audience does too you weren't sure
you wanted this part are you going to
audition for it yeah I kind of got a
little chased down uh for this it wasn't
about not wanting it it just was at a
time in my life where
um I didn't feel like I could I had just
lost my father to pancreatic cancer and
I got the request for an audition like
days after he passed and so I said I
can't possibly make a self tape with my
mom in her living room right now I'm
like no
they said well maybe a couple weeks and
I said uh okay and then I just
grief I couldn't memorize anything and I
just was in such a bad place personally
that I said if I make a tape right now I
think it would be worse than if I didn't
make a tape yeah because especially if
they gave me two extra weeks they'd be
like oh that Bonnie Milligan I really
expected more of her than saying yeah
can and I just said to my agent can you
call me and I told her where I was
emotionally where I was and I said I
would love to work with this team I
would love to work on this piece I am in
no place to make a tape right now
okay we'll check in and they said we'll
give her more time yeah yeah and I was
like wow okay I guess we're doing this
tape and it was just a time where you
really didn't want to make a tape sure
and um I knew the material was special I
knew the team was special
um and we we did that audition tape in
my mom's living room she was the the
reader with me and she did everything
and she hit play on that computer for me
to sing my first song and
um I got it like the next day it was
crazy you play an ant who encourages
children to commit check fraud
[Laughter]
yeah but she's she's she's also got
something else too yeah what is that
I think
a sincere love of Kimberly I think she's
an incredibly selfish person who has
high stakes right now and needs to get
these crimes underway because she's got
to get out of town but to have the
conflict of sincerely loving this niece
and wanting to help her find a little
bit of joy in whatever time she has left
right in the way that I only know how
which is to fight for it yourself and
maybe commit a little crime and it's
whatever it'll make you feel better
and that's kind of like I've always said
it's Deborah's approach to Parenting
it's like her saying this is what I can
pass on to you is that no one will do it
for you yeah you got to do it for
yourself when you walked out on stage
the night I was in here you literally
got a round of applause yeah
that happens sometimes
your performance is kind of a landmark
already yeah it's it's very special to
feel so embraced
by my own Community let alone audiences
and
um feeling
feeling that Embrace and that love is so
moving and special and especially you
know my road to Broadway wasn't easy and
coming back to Broadway even harder and
um to feel like audiences want me up
there is really beautiful and um so
there's such joy and so I think finding
also those moments of Charisma and joy
and fun that Deborah has which is what
causes kids to start singing back up for
her and causes audience to cheer for her
going on is what I as Bonnie can bring
to it and um it's beautiful it's a joy
you got a voice that kind of blows
people away thank you thank you
when did you know you wanted to come to
Broadway
oh gosh I I mean I've loved musicals for
forever what's funny is I remember
saying when I was in high school I don't
know if I have a voice
but I'd love to ask you know and it was
like I love things but I got into
college and that's where I really
started belting and
um so then it was pretty solidified for
me I was like okay we'll do the Broadway
way in your dressing room you have a
picture of your dad I do yeah I've got a
couple what do you think of when you see
him there
I think that he'd be really proud I know
he'd be very proud
um I feel like he has a hand in some
ways pulling strings on the other side
um to help things happen
um so much of this show and so much of
my process early on that was
difficult was separating
trying to separate The Grieving human
and finding my way of
I had just been a person who had been
with someone in their last days and then
doing a show
and I think part of the initial clinging
to Kimberly was Bonnie wanting to cling
to someone who was going and feeling all
the love I could and it's just like
that is just a reminder of like I have
felt this deep intense complicated grief
and this time of
loss but also you're fighting the joy
and you're finding the laughs and you're
finding the hope when it's so hopeless
and so to remember that balance and to
remember how grateful I am there are
days that like you know I stand here and
look at the audience at the end of the
show and we're singing this song about
no one gets a second time around and
just really
taking that in and saying if I'm just
overwhelmed or sad that like this is Joy
though this right now is
what we've worked for and you know you
talk about my voice my voice comes from
my dad my my dad had that big voice and
part of Deborah where you know how she
gets these kids in on her crime is she's
charismatic and she's funny and she's
loud and she's
um bold and that was my dad yeah
and so he was no con artist but like he
was somebody that walked into a room and
commanded it so in a way you pay tribute
to your dad every time you're up there
yeah that's pretty great it's pretty
great you've got a Tony nomination yeah
yeah I can't believe it either it's kind
of mind-blowing really crazy it's
mind-blowing yeah you were kind of
reluctant to take this part
yes yes so I knew I didn't have like the
experience and all of the years of
training and skill that yeah I thought I
would have needed to pull something like
this off you came from Kansas yeah
straight here straight here to take this
part yes this part that was the first
thing I got the the call the self tape
request yeah two years ago yeah and
um I looked at it and I just thought it
was so incredible but that also kind of
created like attention like could I do
this I immediately had so much respect
for it for Janine to story and David
Lindsey a bear they're definitely kind
of Idols of mine so seeing that I was
being called to even maybe be a part of
something of theirs was so crazy to
think that they would see me how did you
find out about the Tony nomination
I was on the phone with my parents we
had a zoom call with some of our
castmates and you know we all got
together and watched in anticipation
hoping for the best
um I certainly wasn't expecting much in
terms of my category but when it
happened I was just like astounded Blown
Away truly I like turned to my castmates
on Zoom they were all cheering I like
unmuted my parents and was like no way
muted them no way
um that's amazing it's really amazing
how does that feel by the way
this this feels crazy I remember the
first time I saw it it was like a little
emotional yeah I remember the first time
I was here for my callback seeing like a
waitress billboard in Times Square and
being like no way
um imagine if I was up there one day and
now I'm here how did you feel once you
got here
when I first got here you know I was I
was ready to live Ready To Live My
Dreams in the city initially my parents
came with me and I was like get out of
here I'm fine I'm gonna have so much fun
but then you know it came in the
responsibility of it yeah um being so
young and coming into a professional
space you suddenly have a responsibility
to the people you're working with to
yourself and I had to learn a lot and
adapt in a lot of different ways like
learn how to cook learn how to go to
sleep on time like wake up and go on a
walk
why do you think this show resonates so
much with young people I think it
resonates so much with young people high
schoolers who are going through exactly
what Kim and Seth are going through and
I think this story is a is unique in a
way because it's a coming-of-age story
right but it really centers around your
strangest like most Outcast members
um of kind of Teenage life and not in
the way of being like a dramatic Outcast
but just being weird and awkward and
vulnerable yeah and I think that's
something that you don't always get to
see and so to see teenagers kind of have
something to represent them in kind of
the parts of themselves that they're
always trying to look away from and
embrace that and show how it's beautiful
and unique I think is really awesome I
remember when Vicky comes out in the
beginning and I look at this and I'm
like and I'm thinking about all the
young people in the audience and I'm
like how are younger people going to
respond to a 60 year old woman playing a
15 year old kid right but it works I
mean it's a testament to her I think she
truly melts away and it's something
about seeing this actress that is so
established so accomplished really bring
herself down like down down to earth
down to the level of me who's actually
19. yeah actually a teenager and we
stand there as equals and I mean it's
really a testament to her skill and
humility and our connection what is that
connection
it's a lot of things I mean she's a best
friend to me she's a mother she's a
grandmother she's a mentor she's
everything and I think that's kind of
what made our characters ring very early
in the in the process was her coming to
me with such Open Arms I mean she knew
how
out of my depth I must have felt and I
was nervous and intimidated and
intimidated by the prospect of working
with her yeah
um but she came to me with kind of an
attitude of that she had something to
learn from me was that connection to
Media
um it was pretty quick I mean she's a
goofy woman so she she came to me
immediately like being just a wacko and
inspired me to loosen up and kind of
share that with everyone yeah I think
what makes the show work is that we
don't feel Trophy and we don't feel like
we're making fun of teenagers we don't
feel like like it's fabricated in any
way and just honing in on that over and
over again I think is what makes the
relationship work people literally walk
out of this show in tears yeah that's
our favorite
this is the whole musical mapped out
yeah what are you laughing at
well yes I mean yeah it's our the last
10 years of Our Lives just on a board
it's a little it's happy sad
well it's nice to see like it's finished
because it was a lot of cards were
moving around for a long time and even
this one you'll see that's in that's in
marker because it was the very last
thing that we did yeah right so I
noticed I noticed you haven't taken it
down no it's never coming back well you
know other things down the pike it might
have to come down
sorry other musicals with Janine that I
have to write okay I have to go up on
that board wow in the sort of run-up to
the show how much does this move around
oh my God it's like Scrabble
I mean it only because I I think the way
that we have worked in an animation
um for my limited experience in
animation this was really helpful
because there's a rhythm to to musicals
and if you don't see enough yellow
there's a problem if you see too much
and so the the colors mean something the
structure of it's not just finishing an
act it's the way that the two acts speak
to each other and then there's
um act three which is what the audience
leaves with they they go and hopefully
that act 3 lasts a really long time
because they're going to be thinking
about that show and talking about that
show also when when we're in the thick
of it and jumping around we never wrote
in order it's really easy to lose you
know the the big picture of it yeah and
so when you put it up there like that
you can say oh look you know we have
four solos in a row you can't do that or
where did Kim go for half of the First
Act whatever it might be you can see
where you need to you know move things
around and yeah help things along well
you're talking about Rhythm I hadn't
thought about it but when you look at
the board you do see a rhythm you see a
rhythm and then you know if there are
ballads that are too close together that
that's it's like a concert but a concert
is a sequence yeah and musicals work
with a kind of inevitability like a
domino game so these are our dominoes
um and hopefully if you line these all
up and then you make them go like this
they can walk away
you've got eight nominations
I mean you all have been in this
business for a while what is it what
does that mean
well it's you know it's thrilling it's a
testament to our team and all the work
that everybody has done yeah it's also
really gratifying because it's a weird
little show it is a weird little show
yeah
life is weird and life is weird but
that's what's wonderful about it yeah I
think so I mean it was right here that
in that bookshelf right 2012.
talking and we plan to do our next
um you know I love riding with David and
um we talked about our next project oh
one of your plays and then I pulled out
that play I was like how about this one
so it
over 10 years ago when I wrote it
initially I was really connecting to the
teenage characters and like conflict
with my own parents and wrestling
through all of that stuff and feeling
unseen and feeling othered and
um I didn't I wasn't so conscious when I
was writing it but now reflecting I was
like oh of course that's exactly what I
was talking about I had lots of emotions
20 years later to now have you know two
two sons of my own and reflecting on the
parents and thinking I don't know
they're not so awful you know I was like
they're full of Terror and fear you know
they're terrified of losing
yeah those are so many people that they
can't handle yes and their coping
methods are to create something else so
they don't feel what's actually
happening yeah speaking for a friend
yeah and it's not to excuse any of their
bad behavior they behave terribly but I
um I feel like 20 years later
re-examining and putting in a song I
understand those grown-ups in a way that
maybe I didn't when I first wrote the
show that oh yeah they're narcissism and
their terrible behavior is grounded in
in absolute Terror yeah so again it
doesn't excuse it but helps explain it
at least and I think those characters
it's a very human response actually yeah
and holidays we traded a lot of holiday
I would say holiday nightmare stories
because in dysfunctional families
holidays are particularly they're the
Festivus of dysfunction and I I remember
talking to David and saying there is
this feeling when a family you know my
three sisters and I what you go through
on holiday days that you think maybe
this holiday will be but you know that
it won't but there is one especially
when you're young you're thinking and
also you know when they open that award
maybe there's a chance they say we won't
get it and then of course you don't but
there's always that shred and so they
know in a way that it's going to turn
but there's also a possibility that this
one night they'll have a peaceful
wonderful time and I was amazed by how
many people thought that's my family
that's how I grew up and I think oh I
guess it's bigger than
just us
will the dinner table scene in
particular this show is so much about
Kimberly living in a place of hope and
wanting your parents to change and maybe
maybe they can be different and maybe
they can treat her the way she wants to
be treated and then we have this moment
the second act where they've finally you
know stepped forward and given her this
amazing beautiful family dinner which is
what she's wanted all along and I
remember Janine saying like I know but
you know when you're at Thanksgiving and
you feel like ah it's gonna be great
everybody's getting along and there's
always that one moment during dinner
when Uncle Tom says the wrong thing or
Aunt Susan brings up a story like and
then it just goes off the rails and
there is this inevitable turn that
happens I was like wait it's what an
inevitable turn and that was the hook
for the song like that's exactly what
the song is about that's what the entire
play is about like hoping and hoping and
hoping and knowing it's probably going
to take that inevitable turn and then
every once in a while it does go your
way it's that sort of one-armed Bandit
way of you know what life is yeah
the night I was there in the audience
there were a lot of young people in the
audience
um
what do you think attracts that younger
audience
well they see themselves I hope and it
really is hitting different audiences in
a way that certainly nothing I've ever
done has hit on those things the young
people I think you know it's a show
about otherness and wanting to be seen
for the people that you think you are
right
um and for the older folks that are
going you know it's also about mortality
and living life to the fullest in the
time that you have left and there's a
lot of parent and and and and child
stuff in there that everybody brings
themselves to the show so what they walk
away with is actually you know in
relation to what they've brought into
the audience so many people seem to walk
out of the theater in tears
why do you think that is
the minor keys
I hope it's people are connecting to the
theme of the show which is life is
precious and
um you know from from the very beginning
we knew that we were not writing a story
about a girl that was dying we were
writing a story about a girl that was
desperately trying to live and so the
the sadness is already baked into the
pie but when they reached the end of the
show we're not ending with her death
we're ending with her going on a great
adventure and so if people leave crying
I think it's because it's out of relief
it's out of Joy it's out of sadness it's
all of those things that you see people
sort of Staggering up the aisles being a
little confused like what did I just
experience I'm so sad and happy at the
same time and so again that's whatever
they bring to it let's buy a mug right
were you worried that the Tony's might
not air of course we were terrified that
Tony's might not air yeah and we're
really thrilled that the WJ found a way
to yeah I mean what a show of I mean
that's collaboration right yeah as the
writers aligned from completely
different parts of the industry our
industry was just devastated he
devastated in a way that I had not
experienced and um and so there was this
incredible understanding and I'm really
grateful how important are the Tonys to
Broadway
incredibly important incredibly
important it's a punctuation to a season
and also shines a really strong Clique
light on on an industry that that
reaches we reach an audience 800
people at a time yeah and for us for
that one night to be able to go out and
say this is what we're doing in 12
blocks in New York City with the hope
that it goes out to your theater to all
you know out on tour it's not just about
New York we live in New York but it's
really about you know giving things
attention I think it has always been
incredibly important because it's our
One National event a year to reach
everybody around the country when I was
growing up I didn't come to Broadway but
I watched the Tonys every year and
watching those numbers and back in the
day seeing scenes from plays they they
help me become a playwright I would see
these things once a year and think oh I
want to do that that's thrilling right
um so yes it's also a commercial for
Broadway and it's always been incredibly
important but now especially after the
pandemic we were essentially shut down
for you know almost two years and we're
finally just getting back like barely
people are starting to return and so the
threat of the Tony telecast being
canceled just that oh gosh we net we
need it this year more than yeah we did
before the pandemic with the complete
understanding
um of what that the strike is a just
strike the stories of all the people the
real life stories of all the people in
the show are almost as compelling as the
show itself
it's just amazing you know where
everybody came from and how all I mean
when and talking to Justin and Annie and
and Victoria it was like each one of
them like kind of didn't really think
they could be in the show
yes which is pretty amazing considering
they're all now nominated for Tony's
yeah right I mean look they are across
the board Extraordinary People more
importantly they're you know amazing
people they also happen to be really
talented actors that know how to act and
sing and walk that tightrope between
humor and heartbreak
um but they're also just good grounded
people that know how to tell a story